now you got this book out thank you for
coming to Hattiesburg
what does the title mean well it's a
book it's a tour diary about doing
smaller market cities like Hattiesburg
and Athens Georgia stuff places like
that and thank you for coming to
Hattiesburg is the type of thing someone
would say when you go to Hattiesburg if
you're like a superstar like me they're
not used to me that's the I feel dirty
for what just happened now our our fans
love delusion yeah so they'll say you
know rather than just going good show or
something go go thank you for coming
here because they can't believe that
you're like if you go to Chicago and do
a show they're not gonna go oh my god I
can't believe an entertainer came to
Chicago cuz everyone goes there but I
first noticed this in Alaska when I did
shows there years ago and I did like a
week of shows in Fairbanks Alaska and
they were just all afterwards like thank
you so much for coming to Alaska thank
you so much like and I was bombing to
night after night oh he wasn't they
weren't even enjoying that thank you for
getting on a plane for 14 hours just to
eat [ __ ] for 45 minutes six straight
nights in a row
now do you enjoy doing I mean book
promotion is a very specific kind of job
and you have to go out and you you you
flog the book about the book you enjoy
doing that sometimes you know I have fun
with it I mean I didn't interview once
for a Canadian public radio and in the
course of the interview I refer to
myself as the hottest comic on the
planet right and I kind of laughed when
I sat in the guy laughed and a few hours
later went on the Internet a woman had
posted that quote and next to it she
wrote this is why I avoid male comedians
from the US and Canada
because you don't understand jokes you
didn't get that you were being you're
being funny yeah I was like a solid
reason to avoid all comedians yeah
specifically born in comedian's of one
gender from only two countries in the
entire world
yeah as I continue to hear more jokes
and not get them I will be adding more
country is this you tie remembered you
mentioned me once that you were when you
tore when you go to a town you like to
find the coffee shop yeah in that town
that's sort of one of your things that
you like to do yeah there's lots of uh
lots of mentions of coffee and this
sound exciting tour diary that I read
but yeah what I mean I will Yelp I will
search a coffee shop at a place that I'm
not playing for six months or something
yeah but I did I did once I looked at I
was in Portland Oregon looking for a
coffee shop and I went on Yelp and I
found a review of place where they said
the baristas here are presumptuous
Brasilia I don't think that's what you
meant to say presumptuous nay I gave you
something to drink
whoa easy tiger I'm sure what I did to
deserve that
that was a sucker punch a coffee shop
gets in the coffee line it's history
like Maggie's in the dream I was warned
about you and a little wax mustache a
little pretentious house already meant
to use yeah I think it was what he meant
to use
you